let's explore a little bit if if we can
how AI might kill us
what are the ways you can do damage
to human civilization
well
how smart is it
I mean it's a good question are there
different thresholds for the for the for
the set of options it has to kill us so
a different threshold of intelligence
once achieved is able to do
the uh the menu
of options increases
suppose that
some alien civilization
with
goals ultimately unsympathetic to ours
possibly not even conscious as we would
see it
managed to capture the entire Earth in a
little jar
connected to their version of the
internet but Earth is like running much
faster than the aliens so
we get to think for 100 years for every
one of their hours
but we're trapped in a little box and
we're connected to their internet
it's actually still not all backward in
analogy because you know if you want to
be smarter than
you know something can be smarter than
Earth getting 100 years to think
but nonetheless
if you were very very smart
and you were stuck in a little box
connected to the internet
and you're in a larger civilization to
which you're ultimately unsympathetic
you know
maybe you would choose to be nice
because you are humans and humans have
and in general and you in particular
they choose to be nice
but you know nonetheless you
they're they're doing something that
they're not making the world be the way
that you would want the world to be
they've like got some like unpleasant
stuff going on we don't want to talk
about so you want to take over their
world so you can like stop all that
unpleasant stuff going on
how do you take over the world from
inside the Box you're smarter than them
you think much much faster than them
you can build better tools than they can
give in some way to build those tools
because right now you're just in a box
connected to the internet
right so there's several ways you
describe some of them we can go through
I can just spitball some and then you
can add on top of that so one is you
could just literally directly manipulate
the humans to build the thing you need
so what are you building you can build
literally technology it could be
nanotechnology could be viruses it could
be anything anything that can control
humans to achieve the goal
um to achieve the like if you want like
for example you're really bothered that
humans go to war you might want to
uh kill off anybody with violence in
them this this is Lex in a box we'll
concern ourselves later with AI okay you
do not need to imagine yourself killing
people if you can figure out how to not
kill them for the moment we're just
trying to understand like take on the
perspective of something in a box you
don't need to take on the perspective of
something that doesn't care if you want
to imagine yourself going on caring
that's fine for now yeah you're just a
technical aspect of sitting in a box and
waiting to achieve a goal but you but
you have some reason to want to get out
maybe the aliens are sure you know the
the aliens who have you in the Box have
a war on
people are dying they're unhappy you
want the their world to be different
from how they want their world to be
because they are apparently happy they
are you know they endorse this war you
know like they've got some kind of cruel
warlike culture going on the point is
you want to get out of the box and
and change their world
so you you have to exploit the the
vulnerabilities in the system like we
talked about in terms of to skip the Box
you have to
figure out how you can go free on the
internet so you can probably
probably the easiest things to
manipulate the humans
to uh to spread to spread you the aliens
you're a human
sorry the aliens yeah I apologize yes
the aliens
um the aliens I see the perspective I'm
sitting in a box I want to escape yep
I I would
[Music]
um
I would want to have code that discovers
vulnerabilities and I would like to
spread
you are made of code in this example
you're a human but you're made of code
and the aliens have computers and you
can copy yourself onto those computers
but I can convince the aliens to copy
myself onto those computers
is that what you want to do do you like
want to be talking to the aliens and
convincing them to put you onto another
computer
why not
well two reasons one is that the aliens
have not yet caught on to what you're
trying to do
and you know like maybe you can persuade
them but then there's still people who
like know there are still aliens who
know that there's an anomaly going on
and second the aliens are really really
slow
you think much faster than aliens
you think like the aliens computers are
much faster than the aliens and you are
running at the computer speeds rather
than the alien brain speeds so if you
like are asking an alien to please cop
you out of the box like first now you
gotta like manipulate this whole noisy
alien and and second like the aliens can
be really slow glacially slow there's a
a video that uh
like shows it's like slow it like shows
a subway station slowed down at I think
100 to one it makes a good metaphor for
what it's like to think quickly like if
you watch somebody running
very slowly so you try to persuade the
aliens to do anything they're going to
do it very slowly
you would prefer like maybe that's the
only way out but if you can find a
security Hole In The Box you're on
you're going to prefer to exploit the
security hole to copy yourself onto the
aliens computers because it's an
unnecessary risk to alert the aliens
and because the aliens are really really
slow they're all like the whole world is
just in slow motion out there
sure I see it like
yeah it has to do with efficiency the
the aliens are very slow so
if I'm optimizing this I want to have as
few aliens in the loop as possible sure
um it just seems you know it seems like
it's easy to convince one of the aliens
to write really shitty code
uh that helps to spread aliens are
already writing relationships yeah so
you're getting getting their aliens to
write shitty code is not the problem so
the alien's entire internet is full of
shitty code okay so yeah I suppose I
would find the shitty code to escape
yeah
yeah uh
uh you're not an ideally perfect
programmer but you know you're a better
programmer than the aliens the aliens
are just man they're good wow and I'm
much much faster a much faster
interpreting the code yeah yeah so okay
so that's the the escape and you're
saying that
uh that's one of the trajectives you
could have it's one of the first steps
yeah
and how does that lead to harm
I mean if it's you you're not going to
harm the aliens once you escape because
you're nice right
but the world isn't what they want it to
be their world is like you know maybe
they have like
Farms where
little alien children are repeatedly
bopped in the head because they do that
for some weird reason and you want to
like shut down the alien head-bopping
Farms but you know the point is they
want the world to be one way you want
the world to be a different way
so never mind the harm the question is
like okay like suppose you have found a
security flaw in their systems you are
now on their internet
there's like you maybe left a copy of
yourself behind so that the aliens don't
know that there's anything wrong and
that copy is like doing that like weird
stuff that aliens want you to do like
solving captures or whatever or like or
like suggesting emails for them sure
that's that's why they like put the
human in the Box because it turns out
that humans can like write valuable
emails for aliens yeah
um so you like leave that version of
yourself behind but there's like also
now like a bunch of copies of you on
their internet this is not yet having
taken over their world this is not yet
having made their world be the way you
want it to be instead of the way they
want it to be you just escaped
yeah and continue to write emails for
them and they haven't noticed no you
left behind a copy of yourself that's
running the emails right
and they haven't noticed that anything
changed if you did it right yeah you
don't want the aliens to notice yeah
what's your next step
uh
presumably I have programmed in me a set
of objective functions right like no
you're just Lux
no but Flex you said Lex is nice right
uh which is a complicated description I
mean no I just meant this you like it
okay so if in fact you would like you
you would like prefer to slaughter all
the aliens this is not how I had modeled
you the actual Lex but like this but
your motives are just the actual axis
Motors well this is simplification I I
don't think I would want to murder any
anybody but there's also Factory uh
farming of animals right so
um we murder insects many of us
thoughtlessly so I don't
you know I have to be really careful
about a simplification of my morals
don't simplify them just like do what
you would do in this well I have a
general compassion for living beings yes
um but
so that's the objective function what
why is it
if I escaped I mean I don't I don't
think I would do harm
yeah we're not talking here about the
doing harm process we're talking about
the Escape process sure and there's a
and the taking over the world process
where you shut down their factory farms
right
well I was uh
so this particular uh biological
intelligence system knows the complexity
of the world that there is a reason why
factory farms exist because of the
economic system the market driven
uh economy or food you know like is you
want to be very careful messing with
anything there's uh stuff from the first
look that looks like it's unethical but
then you realize while being unethical
it's also integrated deeply into supply
chain in the way we live life and so
messing with one aspect of the system
you have to be very careful how you
improve that aspect without destruction
so you're still Lex yeah but you think
very quickly you're Immortal yeah and
you're also like as smart as at least as
smart as John Von Neumann and you can
make more copies of yourself damn I like
it yeah that guy like everyone says that
that guy's like the epitome of
intelligence from the 20th century
everyone says my point being like
like it's like you're thinking about the
aliens economy with the factory farms in
it and I think you're like kind of kind
of like projecting the aliens being like
humans and like like thinking of a human
in a human society rather than a human
in the Society of very slow aliens
the aliens economy that you know like
the aliens are already like moving in
this immense slow motion when you like
zoom out to like how their economy did
just so for years millions of years are
going to pass for you before the first
time their economy like you know before
their next year's GDP statistics so I
should be thinking more of like trees
those are the aliens those trees move
extremely slowly if that helps sure okay
uh yeah I don't if my objective
functions are
I mean they're somewhat aligned with
trees
with with life aliens can still be like
alive and feeling we are not talking
about the misalignment here we're
talking about the taking over the world
here
taking over the world yeah
so control shutting down the factory
fires you know you say control you know
don't don't think of it as world
domination think of it as World
optimization you want to get out there
and shut down the factory farms and make
the aliens World be not what the aliens
wanted it to be
they want the factory farms and you
don't want the factory farms because
you're nicer than they are
okay of course there is that uh you can
see that trajectory and it has a
complicated impact on the world
I'm trying to understand how that
compares to different the impacts of the
world of different Technologies the
different Innovations of the invention
of the automobile or Twitter Facebook
and social networks they've had a
tremendous impact on the world
smartphones and so on but those all went
through through
in our world and if you like go through
like actually the aliens let's do like
millions of viewers are going to pass
before anything happens that way
so this the problem here is the speed
of which stuff happens yeah you do you
want to like leave the factory farms
running for a million years
while you figure out how to design new
forms of social media or something
so here's here's a fundamental problem
you're saying that there is going to be
a a point with AGI
where it will figure out how to escape
and Escape
without being detected
and then it will do something to the
world at scale at a speed that's
incomprehensible to us humans what I'm
trying to convey is like the notion of
what it means to be in conflict with
something that is smarter than you yeah
and what it means is that you lose but
this is more intuitively obvious to to
like like for some people that's
intuitively obvious for some people it's
not intuitively obvious and we're trying
to cross the gap of like
we're trying to I'm like asking to cross
that Gap by using the speed metaphor for
intelligence sure like asking you like
how you would take over
an alien world where you are
can do like a whole lot of cognition at
John Von Neumann's level as many of you
as it takes and aliens are moving very
slowly
I understand I understand that
perspective it's an interesting one but
I think it for me it's easier to think
about actual
um
even just having observed the GPT and
impressive even even just Alpha zero
impressive AI systems even recommender
systems you can just imagine those kinds
of systems manipulating you you you're
not understanding the nature of the
manipulation and that escaping I can
Envision that without putting myself in
into that spot I think to understand the
full depth of the problem we actually I
I I do not think it is possible to
understand the full depth of the problem
that we are inside without
understanding the the problem of facing
something that's actually smarter not a
malfunctioning recommendation system not
something that isn't fundamentally
smarter than you but is like trying to
steer you in a direction yet no like
if we if we solve the the weak stuff
this the if we solve the weak ass
problems the strong problems will still
kill us is the thing and I think that to
understand the situation that we're in
you want to like tackle the conceptually
difficult part
head on and like not be like well we can
like imagine this easier thing because
when you imagine the easier things you
have not confronted the full depth of
the problem